this was the last photo taken of roman
protosavic
just before he boarded the ryanair
flight in athens he was arrested
along with his girlfriend when their
flight was forced to land in belarus
nothing was heard from him for 24 hours
and then this video was released from
his prison
in minsk yesterday evening
my name is yesterday i was detained by
belarusian police at the airport
now i'm in minsk police station one i
can say that i don't have any health
problems with my heart
or any other organs i'm being treated
with respect
and according to the law right now i
continue to cooperate with police
and confessed to organizing mass
protests in minsk
said he believes that his son was forced
to lie on camera
my son cannot admit to creating the mass
disorders because he didn't do any such
thing
it's unlikely he went for a deal with
the prosecutors
i think it's just that he was forced to
record the message
we especially can't understand exactly
when the message was recorded
and how truthful it is
international outrage has come thick and
fast first the uk
banned belarus's flag carrier from
landing in britain
and uk airlines from flying over
belarus's airspace
and then late last night the eu
announced the same
we will not tolerate that they play
russian roulette with the lives of
innocent civilians
this evening in the first part of our
meeting we reacted very quickly
as was necessary given the events
this is an attack on democracy this is
an attack on freedom of expression and
this is an attack
on european sovereignty and
this outrageous behavior needs a strong
answer
the us is on the same page but is yet to
announce any punishment for belarus
although president biden has described
the incident as
a direct affront to international norms
and has hinted at sanctions to follow
lithuania has told its citizens to leave
belarus for their own safety
speculation about russian involvement
hasn't been confirmed
but presidents putin and lukashenko are
reportedly due to meet
later this week the belarusian leader
has very few allies now alistair bunkel
sky news